hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his
metaphysical poem or at least the
fragments that we possess of it we see
Parmenides narrating a choice that he
has to make between two fundamentally
different ways of looking at reality one
of which is the path of being or of it
is and the other is the path of
non-being or becoming the one is true
the other one is false and he ends up
opting clearly for the path of being and
he also tells us about what being is and
by contrast he tells us a little bit
about what not being or non being isn't
because you can't say what it is because
it doesn't have an is and some of the
things that he has to say are are quite
you know pictorial you could say he
talks about it as being like a well
rounded sphere from every side like the
body of it everywhere of equal intensity
from the center and so there are these
spatial just descriptions of it but it's
not as if it's a sphere within a
universe that contains other things it
simply is everything that's
tality and that is some sort of
well-rounded sphere Parmenides is a
monist which means that he thinks that
everything is ultimately one and the
name for that one is being toe a nine so
one of the things that he says early on
in fragment 8 which is where he's giving
the the real description of this is a
little bit paradoxical there's a lot of
paradoxic allottee in this poem itself
he tells us that on the on the route or
path the whole dose the road if you like
of being on this way there are many
signs indicating that what is and then
he tells us about what you know the
characteristics of being are but he says
there are many signs
cemaat a hace polla and so what does he
mean by signs that you could say
criteria you could say indices you could
say ways in which we come to grasp what
the nature of being is according to
Parmenides so what are some of these
characteristics he tells us that it is
unborn egg and a tonne right it is not
generated by anything else and we'll
look at the argument that he provides
for that in just a moment it's also
empirical it cannot go out of being it
cannot be corrupted destroyed in any way
on all a know they're thrown all right
it cannot be just it cannot be undone
you might say by anything else because
there literally is nothing else so he
says it was not once nor will it be
there is no past in which it emerged
there is really no future for it because
it is entirely and this is a really
interesting way
about things it is now new Anesti neuen
is now in in greek write a whole pond
one hand continuous so neck haze so
these are saying that it has all of
these attributes or if you like it is
these attributes in a way that nothing
else could possibly be and it is all of
these now eternally it was that before
from our perspective of before it will
be that in the future from our
perspective of the future but there
really is no before after for for being
itself so he goes on and he says what
birth could you seek for it how and from
what did it grow now these are
rhetorical questions because he's going
to then say neither will I allow you to
say right it didn't it wasn't born from
anything or to think that it grew from
what is not for that it is not cannot be
spoken or thought that's an interesting
argument to make he's not just saying
that you can't get nothing from nothing
right I'm using a double negative there
actually you can get nothing from
nothing you just can't get anything else
from it you can't get something from
nothing he's saying that you can't even
think what non-being is so because you
can't think it nothing could have come
from it it's a little bit different than
merely enunciated the metaphysical
principle that we see in so many other
schemes that nothing comes from nothing
all right so it can't have its origin in
non being at all then he says also what
need could have impelled it to arise
later or sooner if it's spraying from an
origin and nothing there would have to
be some sort of cause some sort of
explanation
something that could compel being to
come out of non-being into being if
indeed this was going to be the
case and the Parmenides does that's
that's simply not the case and it's
unthinkable
so he goes on and and says nor ever will
the power of trust allow that from what
is it becomes something other than
itself so I can't change and here we get
to a really interesting point Parmenides
has just said that being can't be
produced but he uses three different
sort of mythological concepts here
concepts that are going to become
demythologized and later Greek ideas one
is justice DK another is necessity and
non K and then fate maire and he talks
about each of these at different points
in this fragment as in some way binding
or necessitating to you know use a the
very word doing something with being not
in a sense of like before and after but
always doing that so he says this is why
justice has not freed it relaxing the
grip of her fetters either to be born or
to perish no she holds it fast so the
implication here is that if being wasn't
compelled by justice if it wasn't bound
fettered by justice well then it could
in fact turn into non-being or come out
of non-being but since justice actually
compels it in this way that can't be the
case and says the decision on these
matters depends on this it is or it is
not and it has been decided as was
necessary so there's a little again
paradox there a little bit later on he
talks about fate
he says apart from what is nothing else
either is or will
since what is is what fate
Moira bound to be entire and changeless
so again it seems like fate is
compelling being to be what it is and
just a little bit earlier he uses the
term Anan K he says it stays in the same
state and in the same place lying by
itself and so it stays firmly as it is
why for my t necessity holds it in the
bonds of a limit which restrains it all
about because it is not lawful for what
is to be incomplete
so necessity now is is what won't allow
being to you know turn into non being or
to admit of anything you know missing
within it or open itself up now that's
like I said a little paradoxical because
first we're starting with being and this
monism everything is being and that's
all there is and then it seems like
there's something over being whether we
call it fate necessity or justice it
makes being be the way that it is now
here's where it gets more paradoxical if
we think this through that fate that
necessity that that justice would in
fact have to be part of an aspect of
being so really what's going on here if
we think it through is being is
compelling itself to remain within these
limits and not to have relations with
non being or however else we want to put
it to be timeless eternal you know
entirely connected one all of these
these attributes so you know this is
something that is a little bit tricky to
think through what else can we say about
being it's not infinite now the word
that we are translating sometimes in
English as infinite isn't actually
infinite in the sense of Pedro and in
Greek without a limit which is usually
the word translators in
rather better translation incomplete
it's not incomplete to Lao Titone so
Telos means end in Greek to note a tone
means brought to its its end brought to
its fulfillment fully developed I is a
privat of so it's not without having
been brought to its fulfillment and
again there's no temporal succession
here so it's not as if it ever was
lacking any sort of fulfillment it is
entirely what it is and he goes on and
says because there's no lack in it and
then there's something really
interesting that comes up sort of
suggestion if it if it were to lack
anything it would lack everything he
says there is no lack in it if there
were it would lack everything so you
know this is a pure hypothetical
possibility from Parmenides point of
view but he's saying this is one reason
why it cannot be unfulfilled or
incomplete in any way whatsoever to be
infinite is to be in a certain way
incomplete you haven't finished the
series right from a Greek perspective
now he finishes by saying that human
beings have given names Inomata to
things having believed them to be true
and it's an interesting list that he
provides us here he you know he's
contrasting this to being he says both
birth and perishing human beings think
that Genesis birth or coming into being
and perishing being corrupted
disappearing are real things but they're
not real things they're part of that
that path of non-being or becoming what
else he says change of place alteration
of blood of bright colouring those two
moving from one place to another
alteration in one of the most tangible
or
most perceptible qualities right
changing of bright coloring going from
green to red or whatever we want it to
be but then he says and he's using these
very words here what else
human beings think that being and
non-being ni Takei ye being and it's not
our real so does this like upset the
proverbial apple cart at this point or
should we see this as saying that the
ways that human beings understand being
are actually wrong because it's
contrasting being with not being and
there is no not being to contrast being
with that's probably the better
interpretation here so this is what
Parmenides means when he's talking about
being and this first path or route or
Road a way of looking at things there
are as I pointed out quite a few
paradoxes involved in this and it's a
little tricky to wrap our heads around
you